[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue jeu dans europe hebdo
parlement à bruxelles dans l'actualité à
cette semaine et l'irlande un enjeu clé
du breakbeat pour les britanniques
ils craignent une résurgence des
tensions alors que l'accord de paix à
tout juste 20 ans pour mieux comprendre
nous irons à la frontière entre les deux
irlande
mais avant l'actualité en france ce
pilier de la construction européenne est
ébranlée par la crise des gilets jaunes
comment regarde-t-on en europe ce
mouvement spontané et inédit pour en
parler j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur
ce plateau madame linda mcavan bonjour
bonjour vous êtes eurodéputé britannique
membre du groupe des socialistes et
démocrates à vos côtés monsieur philippe
lambert sont jours au président du
groupe verts ici à bruxelles eurodéputés
belges et enfin monsieur philippe juvin
député européen français bonjour membre
du parti populaire européen
alors avant de commencer à débattre je
vous propose de revenir sur ce mouvement
d gilet jaune qui a émergé il y a un peu
plus de trois semaines en france
[Musique]
comment
c'était le 25 novembre emmanuel macron
arrive à bruxelles pour un sommet
consacré au brésil mais il est vite
rattrapé par l'actualité nationale la
veille
des violences ont émaillé la deuxième
journée de mobilisation des gilet jaune
à paris interrogé par la presse sur
cette crise qui ne fait alors que
commencer
le président français gardent le cap
tout en prônant le dialogue
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de projet de
société pas de projet politique au
niveau national et européen
si nous n'apportons pas une réponse
claire à nos classes moyennes et à nos
classes laborieuses
ce qui veut dire une réponse économique
social mais également culturel et de
sens
[Musique]
une semaine plus tard le 1er décembre la
violence monte d'un cran
les gilets jaunes et les policiers
s'affrontent au coeur de paris au pied
de l'arc de triomphe
des images d'émeutes qui font le tour du
monde et de l'europe
à la une du quotidien belge le silence
de l'elysée face au chaos
le mouvement des gilets jaunes au
fronton macron à la pire crise de son
mandat écrit l'espagnol el país le
journal allemand die tageszeitung
apostrophe même le président français
macron entend le signal
inquiète les européens regardent
attentivement ce qui se passe en france
d'autant que le mouvement des gilet
jaune commence à essaimer par petites
touches dans d'autres pays
samedi dernier quelques dizaines de
néerlandais se sont rassemblés à l'oeil
en solidarité avec les gilets jaunes
français en allemagne
un millier de personnes ont manifesté
devant la porte de brandebourg à berlin
à l'appel de trois organisations
d'extrême droite par contre les taxes
mais contre l'immigration mais c'est
surtout en belgique que le mouvement
fait des émules vendredi dernier la
première manifestation des gilets jaunes
à bruxelles a dégénéré khanh hoà aux
voitures de police incendiées
le face à face a duré une bonne partie
de la journée
environ 300 personnes étaient devant les
institutions européennes
quelques français mais surtout des
belges
comme en france il y avait très très
riches sont très haut et a des traits
peau et qui deviennent de plus en plus
en plus pauvres et il va arriver on aura
des millions de gens dans la rue on nous
taxe on nous étrangle travers de taxes
et donc nous on est là dans la rue pour
dire ça on s'en sort plus quoi on a on
n'arrive plus à arriver à vivre la fin
de mois si le malaise français s'est un
peu propagé aux belges francophones
le mouvement des gilet jaune reste
encore sporadiques hors des frontières
de l'hexagone
monsieur lambertz que pensez vous de ce
mouvement d gilet jaune
je pense que c'est d'abord une réforme
contre l'injustice contre l'injustice
fiscale contre la justice sociale contre
l'injustice territoriales je pense que
finalement nos concitoyens ont été très
patients ça fait 30 ans que les
inégalités augmentent régulièrement dans
nos pays et les politiques qu'emmanuel
maquereau a mise en oeuvre ne peuvent
qu'augmenter ces inégalités et je pense
que c'est le signe d'un ras le bol
extraordinaire et donc bien sûr je ne
cautionne absolument rien les violences
de certains extrémistes dans ces
manifestations mais on ne peut pas nier
le fait que beaucoup de nos concitoyens
se sentent complètement laissés pour
compte
laissé pour compte par une
mondialisation néolibérale qui est non
seulement néfaste pour la planète mais
qui en réalité est un jeu à somme
négative pour eux autrement dit ce sont
les perdants de la mondialisation
il est vraiment temps qui on réoriente
les politiques pas seulement en france
mais en europe parce que
fondamentalement ce que ma conférence en
france c'est les politiques de l'ancien
monde néolibéral que nous observons en
europe depuis un quart de siècle madame
mcavan quel regard vous portez vous sur
ce mouvement en france dès gilet jaune
oui donc je suivis les émissions à la
télévision et je tiens à bruxelles
vendredi passé le donc j'étais j'ai vu
les manifestations et je suis d'accord
avec les landais dans le sens qu'il y
avait beaucoup de violence il ya des
mouvements extrémistes mais dedans il ya
beaucoup de deux citoyens qui sont qui
savent pas boucler la fin du mois et je
crois c'est une question d'inégalité
dans la société qui provoque ce genre de
manifestation dans un sens le vote grec
sites au royaume uni c'est un peu le
même le même phénomène des gens qui
sentait qu on est écouté par qu'ils
étaient négligés par le pouvoir
ces gens ils ont voté le break site est
maintenant on voit un peu le même
phénomène dans d'autres pays européens
philippe juvin vous êtes eurodéputés
français est ce que vos collègues ici à
bruxelles
eurodéputé vous parle du mouvement aux
français ce qu'ils s'inquiètent
bien sûr comment ne pas s'inquiéter ce
qui est incroyable c'est que on a là
l'explosion d'une classe moyenne de gens
qui se lèvent tôt le matin qui vont
travailler
qui payent leurs impôts qui payent leurs
taxes et qu'ils ont l'impression d'être
méprisés c'est ça le sujet en france
c'est la conséquence de 18 mois d'une
politique qui est vécu comme un abandon
total des territoires de territoire en
entier qui n'ont plus de services
publics qui n'ont plus de médecins on
peut plus trouver un médecin en france
facilement pour se soigner c'est ça la
réalité des choses
bref je pense que le gouvernement
français doit prendre des mesures là il
ya quelques propositions qui ont été
faites mais elles sont elles arrivent
trop tard
et elles sont trop faibles donc c'est
une véritable révolution de
détoxification qu'il faut mettre en
oeuvre c'est à dire faire en sorte que
les promesses qui ont été faites aux
retraités de ne pas toucher aux
retraites et bien elles soient tenus
emmanuel macron était lui en disant je
ne toucherai pas aux retraites
il arrive ithaque les retraités comment
voulez vous que la parole publique ne
soit plus mis en cause donc moi je dis
qu'en france je suis extrêmement inquiet
parce que on a toute une partie de la
population qui sont des gens qui
obéissent aux lois et qui travaille qui
aujourd'hui se sentent abandonnés et il
faut vraiment que le gouvernement se
mette à gouverner on a l'impression
qu'il est au pouvoir mais en réalité qui
ne gouverne plus alors pour le moment le
mouvement ne concerne que la france mais
est ce que les causes ne sont pas
exactement les mêmes que celles qui ont
conduit à la montée des votes populistes
en europe de l'est à l'élection d'un
gouvernement populiste en italie madame
mcavan oui je crois c'est un peu la même
ce phénomène et je crois qu'on devrait
retrouver en héros la volonté politique
on avait dans la période d'après guerre
donc on doit faire attention au logement
aux salaires aux conditions de travail
parce que pour la plupart des gens ici
voit là mondiale mondialisation ils vont
aller les rangs qui pensent que c'est
que c'est pas pour eux et ça on doit a
réagi à ça et monsieur lombers comment
on fait pour qu est ce qu il faut
changer pour que les gens aient
l'impression que l'europe c'est pour eux
mais je pense que la première chose à
faire c'est de restaurer une forme de
justice fiscale
autrement dit la question n'est pas
nécessairement celle du volume total de
l'impôt mais qui le paye quand emmanuel
macron fait une réforme qui résulte dans
le fait que les 1% les plus riches voix
pouvoir d'achat augmenter de 6% en 18
mois vous imaginez donc les 1% les plus
riches français ont vu leur pouvoir
d'achat augmenter de 6% en 18 mois quand
le reste de la population est appelée à
trinquer jeudi c'est évidemment une
provocation une provocation cette idée
de rendre les riches plus riches et ça
profite à tout le monde est évidemment
un mensonge éhonté et on peut le
rhabiller sous la forme des premiers de
cordée ça ne change rien à la faye et
donc s'ils n'y a pas de geste fort de
justice fiscale par exemple à la remise
en place de l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune
je crains fort que tout ce avec quoi je
veux dire ça n'est pas parce qu'on on
gèle la mise en oeuvre de nouveaux
dispositifs fiscaux que les manifestants
vont être satisfaits ce qu'ils veulent
voir c'est un changement structurel dans
la fiscalité en france et ça je ne crois
pas honnêtement dit que emmanuel macron
qui a une forme d'autisme d'un cas pas
d'incapacité auditionnée sans doute un
mauvais mot mais il est sourd en réalité
à ce que demande le peuple quand
emmanuel macron dit j'ai aboli l'impôt
de solidarité sur la fortune parce que
tout le monde me dit que c'est stupide
web et qui sait tout le monde sait les
gens qu'ils rencontrent et qui rencontre
utile uniquement les gens qui
appartiennent à la classe dirigeante
mondialisée qu'est ce que vous voulez
moi je ne crois pas qu emmanuel macron
être capable en tout cas aujourd'hui
d'entendre le signal
monsieur julien très rapidement est ce
que l'europe a une responsabilité dans
ce mouvement des gilets jaunes
emmanuel macron défend sa politique en
disant il faut respecter les critères
des traces profondes et non non ça c'est
très facile premièrement il faut baisser
massivement les impôts en france quand
vous gagnez 2 euros il y en a un qui est
pris en taxes il faut que le travail
paye
or le travail ne paye plus deuxièmement
pardon de le dire il ya un sujet aussi
sur l'immigration
les gens ont l'impression d'être
déclassé à cause d'une immigration qui
n'est pas contrôlée et puis
troisièmement je pense qu'en france on a
un problème particulier avec le
président de la république je pense
qu'un problème psychologique
sept hommes n'écoutent pas vit sur une
autre planète et d'ailleurs quand on le
voyait dans votre interview tout à
l'heure quand il parlait des classes
moyennes et des classes laborieuses
ce mot de classes laborieuses un petit
côté de 2,2 de maîtrise on a
l'impression qu'on est ailleurs et qu'on
ne vit pas sur la même planète
c'est incroyable exact alors qu'ils
t'ont la france un instant pour
traverser la manche et s'intéresser
l'avenir de l'irlande une question
épineuse auquel les briques sitter en
2016 n'avaient pas vraiment réfléchi
le royaume uni qui t'ont l'union
européenne l'irlande y restons comment
ne pas recréer une frontière au coeur de
lille le conflit qui a endeuillé cette
île pendant 30 ans est encore dans
toutes les têtes les irlandais sont
inquiets clément perreault est allé à
leur rencontre de part et d'autre de la
frontière regarder
sur ses terres le break site est un
sujet ultrasensible
nous arrivons à la frontière des deux
irlande sur la route qui relie dublin et
belfast
dans le bus un groupe de députés
français venez avec moi voici la
frontière membre du groupe parlementaire
d'amitié avec l'irlande
ils découvrent une frontière aujourd'hui
presque invisible si les véhicules sont
à l'arrêt c'est seulement pour permettre
à la délégation de passer quelques
minutes sur place
et là vous êtes en irlande du nord et
moi en irlande et maintenant vous êtes
aussi en irlande les avec le bric site
la frontière comme les embouteillages
pourrait devenir bien réelle au lieu
d'avoir une unité de circulation et bien
ce sont des contrôles ce sont des tarifs
douaniers se sont à cette toute nouvelle
façon de travailler et surtout de perdre
beaucoup de temps nous sommes là depuis
quelques minutes vous voyez les files de
camions qu'il y a dans un sens et dans
l'autre c'est à dire qui viennent soit
de l'irlande du nord soit de la
république d'irlande et une heure de
retard c'est 15 euros supplémentaires
pour le transport le rétablissement de
contrôles aurait de très lourdes
conséquences pour les autorités des deux
irlande
nous aurions besoin de beaucoup plus
d'effectifs pour limiter les retards et
le trafic et pour contrôler chaque
véhicule
ce serait un énorme problème
[Musique]
cette frontière date de 1922 lorsque la
république d'irlande a pris son
indépendance
six comtés du nord on te choisis le
maintien dans le royaume uni l'ont de
500 km son tracé très tourmentée coupant
de deschamps des rivières des lacs
parfois même des églises il a été
négocié ferme par ferme selon que les
familles étaient catholiques ou
protestantes john sheridan est éleveur
ses terres longe la frontière
matérialisée ici par une simple clôture
entre deux champs
il est installé côté irlande du nord on
n'est pas la seule frontière qui existe
aujourd'hui et dans nos mémoires dans
nos esprits nous pouvons voyager
librement maintenant ça 70 % de ma
viande de mouton part vers le sud pour
sa transformation
quels seront les critères à l'avenir
pour exporter de la nourriture n'importe
quelles frontières dites légères
pourrait vite se transformer en
frontières dur à quelques kilomètres de
la frontière cette fois côté république
d'irlande
voici combi lift c'est l'une des plus
grandes usines du pays elle produit des
chariots élévateurs l'incertitude
entourant le bric site pousse les
grandes entreprises à anticiper tous les
scénarios combi lift négocié avec le
gouvernement des solutions pour limiter
la casse en cas d' arbres excite une
sortie dure du royaume uni elle veut
notamment à d'accès à l'eau et à settat
d'accord européen de simplification
douaniers ça nous assurer la libre
circulation de nos marchandises vers le
marché britannique
sinon ces transactions seraient soumises
au tarif douanier internationaux et cela
entraînerait une augmentation de 3 % de
nos prix sur ce marché mais au delà des
questions économiques
il y as en irlande la question politique
les partisans du bric sites sont
nombreux chez les unionistes ces
irlandais du nord qui veulent rester à
tout prix dans le royaume uni une sortie
de l'europe peut exacerber la fibre
nationaliste britannique beaucoup
d'activistes comme jay bryson veulent
lors autour de frontières durs et
maintenant je veux que l'irlande du nord
reste clairement et fortement dans le
royaume uni cette identité doit être
affirmé fermement
je veux une frontière claire et définie
avec la république d'irlande
la police britannique doit pouvoir
librement effectuer les contrôles à sa
frontière
ces images que l'irlande ne veut plus
voir ne sont pas si ancien les accords
de paix de date que de 1998
les affrontements entre républicains
irlandais majoritairement catholiques et
unionistes protestants ont fait 3500
morts en 30 ans le bric site peut-il
raviver ces tensions à belfast beaucoup
le craignent aujourd'hui encore un mur
sépare les faubourgs catholiques et
protestants les portes qui permettent de
le traverser se ferment chaque nuit
probert mclean et gagnait un ancien
combattant de l'ira l'ex organisation
terroriste des républicains irlandais
qui souhaitaient l'unification de lille
il a passé 12 ans derrière les barreaux
pour avoir posé une bombe selon lui
l'irlande est resté une poudrière
les activistes ont toujours accès à des
armes et à du matériel explosif et il
suffit que quelques personnes utilisent
ces armes pour mettre en péril tout le
processus de paix en irlande du nord
avait voté à 56 % pour un maintien dans
l'union européenne
le chef n parti républicain avait alors
rappelé immédiatement à un référendum
pour une irlande unifiée
la demande est restée sans effet pour le
moment
[Musique]
alors pendant 17 mois l'irlande était
l'un des principaux points de blocage
dans les négociations entre l'union
européenne et londres l'accord sur le
breakbeat signé le 25 novembre à
bruxelles ne règle pas tout comment
expliquer madame mcavan que cette
question soit si épineux si sensible au
royaume uni donc vous avez vu dans
l'émission en effet que la paix c'est
très précaire en a signé un accord
seulement il ya vingt ans et on a promis
qu'il n'y aurait pas de frontières entre
l'irlande du nord et la république
d'irlande est donc maintenant avec le
braque si on doit trouver une solution à
ce problème qui n'est pas facile parce
que les conservateurs propres excite ils
veulent pas rester dans le lignon des
douanes hier et on ne peut pas régler le
problème si on ne reste pas dans l'union
douanière et disons que c'est ça le
problème donc il ya un problème de
brandon le référendum
on n'a pas discuté du tout de problème
d'irlande du nord monsieur juin l'accord
prévoit donc pour l'irlande du nord en
maintien dans l'union douanière ou moins
jusqu'en 2020 comme le reste du royaume
uni un accès au marché unique
cela aurait dû rassurer les irlandais
mais on voit bien dans le reportage
l'entrepreneur les verts sont inquiets
finalement l'accord rien réglé mais ils
ont raison d'être inquiets parce que
pour que les gens comprennent bien s'il
ya s'il n'y a pas de frontières entre
les deux irlandais il faut pas qu'il y
en a s'il y en a pas il faut que la loi
soit la même des deux côtés de la
frontière
or d'un côté les britanniques break
sitter seul qui veut quitter l'union
disent on ne veut pas trop tiers mais en
même temps on veut que les lois soient
différentes
or c'est par définition impossible donc
les gens ont raison d'être inquiets
écoutez franchement on l'avait dit avant
le référendum et les gens ont fait
semblant de ne pas entendre pas écouter
donc la proposition que nous faisons
nous en europe
c'est effectivement qui est pas de
frontière que la loi soit la même de
part et d'autre de celle ci c'est à dire
dans toute l'irlande mais effectivement
ou du coup il ya un moment où la
frontière entre le royaume uni et
l'europe galles se situera bien quelque
part elle se situera probablement en mer
d'irlande si on veut considérer que la
grande bretagne sort une certaine
manière de l'union européenne monsieur
lambertz vous aussi vous estimez que du
coup l'accord du 25 novembre ne règle
pas cette question irlandaise
mais si justement il la règle alors
grand dam de brétigny pour combien de
temps tout pour de manière d'une manière
à définir c'est bien ça ce qui est
difficile à avaler pour les brics
hauters c'est que ce qui est écrit dans
l'accord c'est que tant qu' il n'y aura
pas d'autre solution
eh bien le maintien de du royaume uni
dans son ensemble au sein d'une union
douanière avec l'union européenne sera
d'application autrement dit de royaume
uni va rester très étroitement associé à
l'union européenne pourquoi à cause d'un
accord de paix certains considèrent que
cet accord de paix peut être déchirés et
jetés aux oubliettes je pense que c'est
une irresponsabilité politique total
sept accords lient le royaume uni si le
royaume uni décide unilatéralement de se
retirer de l'accord de paix il devient
un état voyou c'est à dire un état dont
la signature sur les traités
internationaux ne vaut plus rien du tout
qui va encore aller signer un accord que
ce soit les 27 états de l'union ou
n'importe qui d'autre sur la planète
avec un état voyou
je vous le demande et donc non le
royaume uni va rester très étroitement
associé à l'union européenne et on se
demande alors à près après coup tout ça
pour ça
est-ce que ça en valait la chandelle
bonne nouvelle la cour européenne de
justice est sur le point de dire qu'en
fait le royaume uni peut révoquer sa
lettre par laquelle il a signifié son
intention à l'union européenne de la
quitter autrement dit s'il se trouve une
majorité de gens courageux responsable
au royaume uni et bien le royaume uni
peut faire marche arrière il nous aura
coûté beaucoup de soucis pendant
plusieurs années mais je pense que la
sagesse recommande le maintien du
royaume uni au sein de l'union
alors là le parlement britannique doit
encore valider l'accord de retrait signé
à bruxelles le 25 novembre
est ce que madame mcavan cette question
irlandaise a beaucoup de poids dans les
débats au parlement britannique ces
jours ci oui oui cette année parce que
c'est le problème exact c'est comment
est-ce qu'on peut régler le marc le fur
le marché unique avec l'accès aux
pierres briques de frontières donc le
voc serral mardi prochain et d'après ce
que j'ai entendu ce matin il ne sera pas
votée cet accord parce que les profs de
break sitter il semble contre
l'accord et ceux qui veulent rester elle
dans l'union européenne sont contre
l'accord donc il ya un gars civile au
sein du parti conservateur du tourisme
hier elle à perdu le contrôle de son
parti et du chant modique de commun dans
le parlement
elle a perdu trois votes première voir
dans 40 ans qu'un gouvernement peine 3
vente dans une seule journée
donc à mon avis c'est pas finir le break
site
oui dit mardi un vote préliminaire a
montré que les opposants internes jamais
été très nombreux ils ont renvoyé une
première victoire donc c'est un très
mauvais présage un mauvais signal pour
la ratification de cet accord par le
royaume uni qu'est ce qui va se passer
si le 11 décembre au royaume uni
les députés votre compte l'accord de
retrait il n'y a personne qui sait pas
moi par terry semel des parlementaires
eux mêmes ne savent pas parce que à
l'heure actuelle il n'y a pas il n'y a
pas d'accord sur rien il n'y a pas
majorité pour pour le break si tu n'as
pas majorité pour nouveau référendum il
pas majorité pour d'autres solutions
pour la corderie demain donc c'est
difficile à dire dans la balle et zynga
ne sais vraiment pas ce que ce qui va se
passer
voulait travailler s'il n'y a pas de
signature de cet accord qu'est ce que
vous proposez nous on veut rester dans
l'union douanière qui voudraient en
partie les problèmes d'irlande du nord
et on voudrait être très proche du du
marché unique et on pense que trees
messine sicile aides mardi prochain
devrait donner sa démission et convoquer
des élections mais si elle ne fait pas
ça à mon avis on devrait penser en
deuxième référendum parce que si le
parlement ne peut pas régler la question
on doit demander au peuple monsieur juge
nancy
theresa may n'arrive pas à faire adopter
son accord qu'est ce qui se passe au
niveau européen ça veut dire qu'il faut
recommencer les négociations entre
l'union européenne et l'ombre n'ont
formellement si le parlement
britanniques refusent l'accord le 1er
avril prochain la grande bretagne et en
dehors de l'union comme un pays tiers
sans aucun accord international et tous
les toutes les analyses économiques
montrent que ça sera une catastrophe
pour le royaume uni
avec une diminution de l'ordre de 10% du
pib en quinze ans et finalement ils
auront payé plus en perte de richesse
d'appauvrissement que ce qu'ils payent
aujourd'hui à l'union européenne
c'est une tragédie pour le royaume uni
on parle de files d'attentes dans les
hôpitaux de difficultés dans d'obtention
de produits alimentaires de produits
pharmaceutiques etc
ça sera une catastrophe pourtant il ya
des solutions la solution serait d'aller
vers un accord à la norvégienne vous
savez la norvège n'est pas membre de
l'union européenne mais appliquent la
quasi-totalité des règles que l'union
européenne s'impose à elle-même à part
la politique agricole commune la pêche
etc et reconnaît évidemment le rôle
important de la cour de justice de
l'union et participe même au financement
d'actions qui la concerne et je crois
que les conservateurs britanniques ne
veulent pas là mais en fait les
conservateurs britanniques ne veulent ne
veulent rien au fond ils mettent des
conditions à tous et continua à demander
un peu comme un enfant avant la venue du
père noël des choses qu'ils savent
impossible à mettre en oeuvre
je crois que ce break site si vous me
permettez ce qu'on en observe ça doit
nous servir de leçon à nous dans les
pays de l'union ont particulièrement en
france
quand je vois que marine le pen continue
à être très ambigu sur une sortie de
l'union européenne
une sortie de l'euro si elle était au
pouvoir et même jean luc mélenchon joue
avec beaucoup d'ambiguïtés moi je dis
tout simplement aux français qui parfois
sont tentées sur un vin d'un vote
extrémiste vert marine le pen monsieur
mélenchon regardez ce qui est en train
d'arriver aux britanniques ils sont en
train de se suicider et ça moi je ne
veux pas pour mon propre pays monsieur
lamberth vous vous pensez qu'on se
dirige vers un échec de theresa may au
parlement et donc vers un arbre exit au
printemps prochain
avocat j'espère que non parce que ce
serait en effet totalement irresponsable
le gros problème en fait c'est que les
deux principaux partis le parti
conservateur de madame et mais aussi le
parti travailliste madame akhavan sont
profondément divisés sur la question
c'est à dire gomme en leur sein
cohabitent des gens qui veulent rester
dans l'union des gens qui veulent
quitter l'union c'est bien que
j'ai une copine est un prédateur il
voudrait quitter l'union et donc à un
moment il faut savoir le problème si
vous voulez c'est que la parole de ces
partis et quelque part prisonnière de
ses contradictions
je pense que le plus logique serait en
effet de demander au peuple qu'il se
prononce maintenant qu'il sait ce que
signifie le break site
il peut alors voter en connaissance de
cause et dit voilà nous choisissons
entre le maintien dans l'union nous
connaissons les conditions et le break
si nous en connaissons les conditions
aussi et donc faisons notre choix et je
pense que ça c'est la seule manière de
résoudre ce noeud gordien et j'espère en
tout cas que nous pourrons arriver à un
choix et de préférence par la voie d'un
second référendum qui permettra aux
britanniques de décider je vous voyais
madame macadam réagir aux propos n'est
selon bert si vous n'êtes pas tout à
fait d'accord avec ce qu'il vient
d'expliquer non le parti conservateur
c'est dans une guerre civile dans mon
parti on a une position très claire et
le problème des breaks sitter c'est
qu'il veut la voix il avait promis qu'on
pouvait rester qu'on pouvait faire tous
les inventeurs et vous aviez les briques
sitter au sein du parti
mais est ce que très très peu très très
peur non mais par dont le parti
travailliste est aussi très ambigu parce
que dans les points qu'il a publié dix
nous voulons rester dans le marché
unique mais pas dans tous les aspects du
marché unique en particulier sur la
libre circulation des personnes
nous ne voulons pas les européens le
marché unique explose et donc
malheureusement tout le monde joue
l'ambiguïté de semis mensonge on ne
disons pas totalement la vérité les
conservateurs et malheureusement aussi
les travaillistes même si la vérité
historique commande de dire que l'afer a
commencé quand l'ancien premier ministre
a voulu régler un problème interne au
parti conservateur
et pour ça il l'a fait exploser son pays
malheureusement les travaillistes ont
pas été très vertueux je suis dans des
bars à laleu heureusement avec vous sur
david cameron l'ancien premier ministre
et soyez en sûr comme à venir trois
conférences y penser que ce sera facile
référendum qu'ils allaient gagner
facilement seulement et puis maintenant
on voit le résultat je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec le restera comme un des
pires problèmes de son tour de la grande
bretagne
oui absolument pour conclure en fait
c'est l'impasse en ce moment
non je crois que nous devons attendre le
vote à la chambre des communes je pense
que la partie est encore loin d'être
terminé donc ceux qui affichaient
l'autre jour au parlement européen de la
tristesse c'est un petit peu comme si le
match était joué le match n'est pas
encore joué
il ya encore pas mal de jeux et de 7,1 à
jouer et donc je continue à croire que
toutes les issues sont possibles en
effet abrite non négociée qui serait
dramatique pour le royaume uni mais qui
aurait un impact négatif de la slovaquie
oui mais non c'est pas le parlement qui
décide je veux dire tout nouveau ça fait
partie des illusions du parti
travailliste si rien ne se passe
automatiquement le royaume uni sort sans
accord le parlement peut dire nous
faisons ça c'est pas le parlement qui
est aux manettes c'est le gouvernement
dit de vos manettes c'est pour l'instant
l'option par défaut c'est-à-dire en
l'absence d'une autre position 7 abric
site sans accord donc cette possibilité
là existe elle serait très dommageable
au royaume uni elle serait dommageable
pour les vingt-sept c'est très clair par
contre je pense que je pense je suis
peut-être un optimisme d'un optimisme
inébranlable mais je pense que
finalement on s'acheminera souad vers
une rétractation du mexique soit vers
l'acceptation de l'accord tel qu'il a
été négocié mais une renégociation de
cet accord n'aura pas lieu tout
simplement parce que c'est le seul
accord qui respecte à la fois les lignes
rouges du gouvernement britannique et
les lire ou de l'union européenne et
celle là ne font pas changer avec un
autre premier ministre britannique
merci beaucoup fait d'avoir été avec
nous merci à vous de nous avoir suivis
pour cette émission d'europe est au
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro
[Musique]